order the fractions from least to
greatest so we have three fractions and
we want to decide which one is the
smallest which one's in the middle and
which is the greatest
so one thing we could do is look at the
fractions think about what they mean and
then estimate
seven tenths let's say maybe that could
represent seven of your ten friends are
wearing blue jeans well that's most most
of your friends are wearing blue jeans
and then for one third we could say one
of your three teachers wears glasses
well that's not most if only one of the
three wears glasses that's not most of
the group
so here's a fraction that represents
most of the group here's one that
doesn't so the most is probably greater
these two we could compare by estimating
and see that this one seven tenths is
probably greater than one-third
but then we get over here to five-sixths
and five out of six well again that's
most of the group but is this most of
the group greater than the seven tenths
most of the group that gets a lot
trickier
so what we can do is we can try to
change these fractions to make them
easier to compare so we don't have to
compare tenths to thirds to six because
those are all different sizes different
size groups different size pieces that's
tricky to compare so we want to change
these to be the same size
so we need some number a multiple of 10
3 and 6 something we can multiply 10 3
and 6 by
to get a new denominator that will work
for all of the fractions
one way i like to figure this out is i
look at the biggest denominator which is
and i think of its multiples the first
multiple is 10 because 10 times 1 is 10.
can we
change thirds and 6 to have 10 as a
denominator is there any whole number
you can multiply 3 times to get 10
there's not so we need to keep going 10
doesn't work the next multiple of 10 is
10 times 2 which is 20.
again 3 and 6 is there a whole number we
can multiply them by to get 20
again no so 20 doesn't work how about 30
let's see 3 we can multiply 3 times 10
to get 30 so
30 works for 3 how about 6.
6 times 5 equals 30. so yes
30 can work to be our common denominator
30th
30 is a multiple of ten three and six
so let's start converting our fractions
to have denominators of thirty we'll
start with seven tenths
and we want it to have a denominator of
thirty
so what do we need to multiply by
10 times 3 is 30.
we always multiply the numerator and
denominator by the same number
so 7 times 3 is 21.
so 7 10 is equal to 21 30. these are
equal we've just changed the size of the
group we've changed the denominator
so that they will be easier to compare
but we've not changed what portion of
the group we're representing 7 out of 10
is the same portion as 21 out of 30.
and then let's keep going with one third
again we want a denominator of 30 so
this time we'll multiply 3 times 10 to
get 30.
again numerator also times 10 1 times 10
is 10.
10 out of 30 is the same as 1 3 if you
have 10 of the 30 people again we'll use
the wear glasses example or one third
that is the same size of the group the
same portion
and finally 5 6
what do we need to multiply here to get
30 six times five is thirty so we
multiply the numerator times five and
five times five is twenty five
so now instead of these original
fractions that were tricky to compare
we have much easier numbers to compare
we have twenty-one thirtieths
ten thirtieths
and twenty-five thirtieths
so in this case the pieces are all 30th
they're all groups of 30. so this is
much easier to compare
we can simply look at the numerators to
see what portion of those 30 the
fraction represents
so the first seven tenths is the same as
21 out of 30 whereas one-third is 10 out
of 30. well clearly 21 out of 30 is a
larger portion of the group than 10 out
of 30. so we were right when we
estimated up here that seven tenths is
larger than one-third
but then the trickier one over here now
we can see much more clearly 25 out of
30 is the greatest portion of the group
25 is more than the 10 or the 21.
so we can list these now from least to
greatest
the least the smallest is 10 30 which
again remember is equal to one-third
so we can put one-third is least
and we can cross that off
next it's either 21 out of 30 or 25
21 is less and that represented seven
tenths
so we can say seven
tenths because twenty one thirtieth
equals seven tenths
and finally that leaves us with twenty
five thirtieths which is equivalent to
five
six
so from least to greatest our fractions
are 1 3 7 10 and then 5 6.